Studies of children that we are born
with,
this instinct for what's called
substance dualism.
The idea that the,
the body and the mind or soul,
however you want to think of the psyche
are separate.
Children who are as young as three or
four years old who have not grown up
with any kind of religious instruction
naturally assume that they have a soul,
and so I think a lot of theorists
believed that this is this belief in the
soul is universal.
That it can be traced back deep into our
evolution.
Why?
There's a whole host of reasons for
that.
I mean,
I suppose that if you're an unbeliever,
you think that it's just some kind of
evolutionary accident.
It's a trick of the mind,
if as it were,
that makes you think that you are an
immaterial being inside a material body.
If you're a believer,
you think that it's probably because
there is a soul and maybe perhaps that
we were intentionally created in such a
way as to think that there is more to us
than just the material realm.
It's really a choice,
but what cannot be denied is that belief
in the soul is a belief that all peoples
share regardless of their culture or
their religion,
and it's a belief that goes back as far
back in time as we can possibly a trace
it.
And if these psychological studies that
I was talking about are right,
it's a belief that we're born with over
the last couple of hundred years,
there's been an enormous amount of
thought that's gone into the question of
why religion.
You know,
the one thing that we all agree on is
that religion has been a part of the
human experience from the beginning.
In fact,
we can trace the origin of religious
experience to before homo sapiens.
We can check,
we can trace it with some measure of
confidence to neanderthals.
We can measure it with a little less
confidence all the way to homo erectus.
So we're talking hundreds of thousands
of years before our species even
existed.
So the question is why?
You know,
if religion is a universal phenomenon or
rather I should say,
religious experience.
If religious experience is a universal
phenomenon,
if it can be traced in all peoples,
all cultures,
and throughout all time,
then there must be some evolutionary
reason for it.
There must be a reason,
some adaptive advantage to having
religious experience or or faith
experience,
uh,
otherwise it wouldn't exist.
And so there have been over the last
couple of centuries,
numerous attempts to figure out exactly
what that adaptive advantage would be.
The most popular explanation of course,
is the sociological one,
that religion creates a sense of
cohesion amongst a group and that that
sense of cohesion,
the idea that we could come together and
create a collective identity based on
shared symbols or shared metaphors gave
an adaptive advantage to believing
communities that nonbelievers
communities did not have.
That's a pretty good answer.
The problem is that religion is as much
a divisive issue as it is a cohesive
one.
It says a good at creating outgroups as
it is in groups,
and more importantly,
the problem with that,
the social cohesion theory,
is that a kinship was a much more
powerful and much more dominant form of
social cohesion than religion was.
Our ancestors lived in small communities
that were bound together by,
by blood,
by relationship,
by,
by kinship,
a long before they created symbols and
mythologies in order to unify them.
So it's a pretty good answer,
but it doesn't really,
it doesn't really explain what adaptive
advantage religion would have had.
Others have said,
well,
it's about giving us,
you know,
answers to the,
the unanswerable questions of the world
that what it did was create a sense of
um,
uh,
knowledge about the universe that
lessened anxiety in some way.
Uh,
and that was an adaptive advantage.
Well,
even if that were true and there's truly
no reason scientifically to think that
it was,
it's really hard to make an argument
about why that would necessarily be an
adaptive advantage,
particularly because religion actually
causes far more anxiety than it lessons.
In fact,
to put it in evolutionary terms,
the cost of religious expression is
enormous.
It's enormous in terms of time.
It's enormous in terms of the cognitive
processes that are involved in it.
Um,
it,
it sort of creates greater anxiety when
you feel as though your actions have
cosmic significance.
All of this is to say that the countless
different answers that have been given
for why religion fail,
primarily because they're functionalist
answers what they primarily say is what
religion does,
not why religion exists,
and so a group of cognitive scientists,
particularly cognitive scientists who
focus on religion,
have tried to look to a different way of
answering this question of why religion
and what they've discovered is that
number one,
there is in the end,
no adaptive advantage to religious
faith.
And number two,
that the reason that religion exists,
it's big,
is because it is an accidental byproduct
of some other adaptive advantage.
And here we get into very complicated
conversations about cognitive theory and
the development of our frontal lobes and
things like that.
But to put it in its simplest way,
religious thinking is embedded in our
cognitive processes.
It is a mode of knowing we're born with
it.
It's part of our DNA.
The question then becomes why.
One answer is that there is no why.
It's just simply an accident of other,
much more important,
much more necessary,
uh,
cognitive,
adaptions,
uh,
adaptations I should say.
Um,
or if you're a believer,
you would say because we were made that
way because we are designed to believe
that there is more to this world than
the material realm,
that that mode of knowing that exists in
our brain is there for a reason.
Either answer is fine.
There are some people who say,
well,
what religion really does and the reason
that it exists is that it creates some
morality,
right?
That,
uh,
if we,
if we imagine that there's this absolute
moral law giver,
then we're less likely to kill our
neighbor.
And that creates some sort of adaptive
advantage.
The problem with that theory of course,
is that the concept of a moral law giver
is barely 5,000
years old and religious expression goes
hundreds of thousands of years.
I mean,
if you even think about the Mesopotamian
gods or the Egyptian gods,
and this is against seven or 8,000
years ago,
these were not moral beings.
On the contrary,
they were amoral and often immoral
beings.
So the idea that religion is about
morality is a very new idea.
Others say that religion is about a
authority.
It's a,
it's a way of maintaining control and
power over a group and perhaps those
groups that were religiously inclined
had an adaptive advantage because that
notion of an authority structure allowed
them to survive better.
Again,
that's a pretty good answer.
The problem is,
is that you're talking about
institutionalized religious expression,
which maybe maybe it's 12 to 14,000
years old,
uh,
that's as far back as we can trace
anything that looks like an
institutional religious authority.
And again,
that does not explain why religion
existed hundreds of thousands of years
before that.
The truth of the matter is we just don't
know,
but what is a fact is that there is
something in the way that our brains
work that compel us to believe that we
are more than just the sum of our
material parts.
That thing is either an echo or an
accident or it's deliberate and
purposeful and which you decide is
purely a matter of choice because there
is no proof either way.